des oeufs des poules ou des canards les
cloches de pâques ont déjà investi les
pâtisseries
à quelques jours de la fête chrétienne
les chocolatiers sont à pied d'oeuvre
dans cette boulangerie pâtisserie de
versailles plus d'une tonne de chocolat
sera préparé pour l'occasion on est à
350 400 kg à peu près de friture et au
praliné ouais bon enfant en moyenne 40
50 kg
en après-midi quoi tous les jours on est
organisée le matin on fait la nuit on
travaille le matin ont fini nos de
fabriquer nos pâtisseries pour les
magasins et tout et après toute la
journée jusqu'au soir on fait du
chocolat ou en période de pâques
donc c'est grosse activité le labo photo
en 24 sur 24 des classiques indémodables
qui représente ici 80 % des ventes de
chocolat à cette période les 20%
restants sont tenus par ses créations
une biche à un lapin ou une girafe plus
élaborés ces personnages nécessite un
travail minutieux presque de l'art nous
faisons une collection nous coller une
collection en série limitée se sont pas
des moulins s'est réalisée à base de
demi sphère et et de deux petits de
petits moules à fait voilà nous
fabriquons les yeux les expressions nous
donnant des couleurs aussi ce qui fait
le sujet c'est surtout la couleur si
week end pas de lyon ni d'hippopotames
mais des veaux et des poussins une mini
ferme sera installé devant la boutique
pour fêter pâques